- Hey everyone.
First of all, very happy to be here
to talk about how we help our customers
modernizing credit risk application
and make the best out of
solving concrete problem
using Agentic AI in this case.
So I'll talk a lot about
finance. Why is this happening?
Why we need AI agents
in order to solve some
of the credit risk challenges
that banks are facing,
particularly for business banking.
First, you know, who am I? I'm Adrien.
I'm the Global Director of
AI solution for Cloudera.
So what do I do?
I help our customers around Cloudera,
Cloudera AI to make use of the platform
and to solve the right use case
with the right solution.
So, you know, first banking,
you know, banking is the
most impacted by GenAI.
That's correctly, I think
according to McKinsey,
we are looking at the $340
billion potential value creation
thanks to a generative AI.
But it's not that we are
looking at 340 billion,
that it's gonna happen overnight, right?
There's still a lot of
challenges that we see on this.
The first one you know, is
integration in existing process.
If you look at the bank, a lot of legacy,
a lot of system that
have been here for years
and you need to make sure
that the system can get
connected to an AI system.
When you look at training the people,
entire processes were revolving
around manual processes,
human driven,
and you have to rethink them
on how do you move this process
to become AI-driven with human control,
which is a very different taxonomy.
It's not just like sprinkling
some AI on top of a process
and hoping something good happen.
And you look of, you see a
common topic for banking,
AI safety, guardrails.
How do you ensure that
the process is still safe
and that you're not
sending your credit data
to the wrong person or
the wrong actors, right?
But first let's get back to Cloudera.
So Cloudera, we are an
AI and data platform.
We try to, we claim that we can do,
you know, from your data
ingestion all the way
to your AI on one platform
with a single control plane,
with a single security layer.
We are completely hybrid.
Obviously our preferred partner is on AWS.
That's where most of our
customers are using them
when they are on cloud.
Can also do it on premise.
So we try to really be a
bridge between the two.
For customers who might want, you know,
to do a zero code refactoring
move to the cloud,
they can obviously do it.
We provide a unified data
fabric. What does it mean?
It means that for all your
application from the ingestion
all the way to your AI,
you are managed with a
single security schema.
You don't need to reproduce
some like security rule
somewhere else.
And then you realize that your
access policy do not match.
Then you get 25 audit findings
and your bonus decline at the end.
I was head of AI for a bank
and I know that when you
get too many audit findings,
the bonus goes down.
There's a, there was a rule like this,
I discovered it the
hard way at some point.
We provide the open data
lake house obviously
as a foundation to AI application,
but also to reporting
and any kind of more traditional
things you want to do
with your AI, like with your lake house.
But today we'll focus a lot
more on the application layer.
Why? Because obviously we
have a big shift towards AI.
That banks, financial institution,
the largest particularly in the US,
have been investing
heavily on data lake house
and now it's money time, you
know, make this data to use
and be able to build
application, refactor application
and get some business
impact leveraging AI.
We do this, you, we do this even more
on the advantage of Cloudera,
which is private AI.
Private AI obviously is
very convenient for us
in a financial service industry.
Financial service industry,
meaning we are able
to provide this within your
own VPC, whether it's on cloud,
whether it's on-prem,
everything remains within
a single environment.
So you can deploy models,
whether it's an LLM
or a credit risk model
in the same cloud estate if you want,
which is really something
where the Cloudera
clients appreciate on it.
We do value a lot of open source.
So most of our stack is open
source. Why no vendor lock-in?
I always say, if you don't like us,
you can take the code and go
on open source if you want.
Which is I think a testimony
on the value we generate.
Clients are willing to pay for us,
not because they are locked in,
but because we do provide
them a lot of value.
And the last part, you know, is hybrid.
Like I say on cloud, on-prem,
you can use the estate as much as you want
and deploy the code wherever
you would like to have.
Okay, let's get back to our applications.
You know, Agentic AI,
when I talk to customer,
they tell us, you know, we do
see a lot of potential value.
The potential value is 50%
improvement in the process
and particularly for business
banking, commercial banking.
Why is that?
Because if you look at the
landscape of credit origination
for mortgages in most country,
it's heavily automatized.
Even in the US you know,
you have a credit bureau,
you get a score, you
have almost, not perfect,
but close to perfect information.
So, automation is always there.
The real pain point for banks,
and when I ask some of them
well, is the, you know,
how much time do you spend more tell us?
SMEs is where we spend a lot more time
and that's why the spreads
for SMEs are very high,
because operational costs are high
and it's also difficult for them
to get good insight on what's happening.
Why?
Because when you are an SME,
sometime you don't get audited
or the audit report is very different
from one company to another.
They work in very small businesses.
So you really have a
tremendous opportunity there.
But you know, in an ideal
world, we don't need this.
In a nice world, we have
perfect information,
perfect trust and perfect decision.
What does it mean?
It means that we have great data coming
from great P and L statement
that are uniform and everything.
That's what you see on large corporation.
That's not what you see
on smaller enterprise.
You have perfect trust.
When a company gives you a document,
you know this document is trustworthy.
Obviously that's not true,
especially when you start
looking at international lending
and other, let's say less
well-known enterprise.
And you have perfect decision.
Given the information that you have,
you can make a decision that you know
with certainty what is the risk
you're taking on this loan?
Meaning your credit risk model
should be working fine, right?
That's obviously not the case, right?
We do have a lot more
friction that are remaining
when you look at the
loan origination process.
You go from an application, verification,
underwriting at some point
and then maybe some approval if it's good.
Here, what do you see as key blockers?
Well, you see quite a lot, right?
Documents. Many of them
are going to be physical.
Especially when it's an audited statement,
you still find them with a stamp
and even if it's a DocuSign,
it does not help much more, right?
You have policies inside the bank,
so the policy against
which you're supposed
to match the credit application.
This policy, what is it?
It was written by human for human,
it's not returned by an AI,
it's not readily enforceable.
And then later on, you know,
you'll see covenant monitoring and others.
So you have obviously a
heavy human intervention
in this particular processes.
Whether it's application,
collecting the document,
then saying, "Hey, you're
missing this file."
Making a decision.
Yes, there are machine learning models
that are making decisions,
but if you look at the
machine learning models
for enterprise and small
and medium enterprise,
the human input and the expert
input, how they call it,
is still quite heavy, right?
So that's why we do see
that there's still quite
a lot of opportunities
and the opportunities
you know, are numerous.
First of all, an AI-powered origination.
Can you make the document
review more seamless?
Can you review credit memo
and states against this policy,
this credit memo seems to match
or hey, there are some deviation.
Here, the deviation,
please go reach an approval
for a certain, by a certain authority.
Could be a chief risk officer,
it could be just a director,
compliance, anyone, right?
And the last one is obviously
AI-powered loan management.
We do see some banks now doing
automated call collection.
I was working at at a bank before in Asia
and instead of having people
calling for loan connection,
they put a chatbot to it
and if the chatbot managed
to reach out the person
that is being passed to a loan processor.
So maybe, and in the US I know some
of you might be receiving some calls
that are automated from the banks
in order to try to get
you to pay back the loans.
And then later on, you know,
we can also have
AI-powered loan management.
Yeah, risk review.
And risk review is something
that is very simple,
yet very complicated.
For enterprise, it's any
new information may lead
to a risk review.
Think about it like this.
Tomorrow a board member of
this enterprise is changing,
what are the implication
from a risk standpoint
for this particular credit?
Might be nothing, but if
you have to do it manually,
you have to research, oh,
this person is on the board.
What is the name
screening for this person?
What is the new risk scoring that we see
and so on and so forth, right?
So it might not be straightforward.
For today, we're gonna
focus a lot more on, okay,
I have a policy, I have a credit memo.
How do we know that this policy
and this credit memo are matching?
And we do have some customers
really actively investing a lot on this.
Why? Because that's a very
large bottleneck on it.
So we have a credit risk policy
written by human for human,
might be a mortgage policy,
it might be an enterprise policy.
We have a risk memo
and basically the credit
policy is gonna state,
"Okay, your loan to value must be 80%."
Does this credit proposal fulfill this
or do we need an escalation process?
That's a process that can
take really a lot of time
and leads to loan being postponed
and not being approved in time.
So we are going to have a demo
where we create an agent
per rules in the policy
and then this agent can be
matched against the credit memo.
That can be seen as a create
application from an enterprise.
Before that, you know,
the process that we have chosen for this,
that we will have a
creation for each agent
by reading the policy, an
AI system can understand
what are the right agent to extract
and what are the right agent to create
so that you get a list
of, in this example,
having couple of hundred of
agents, then we can select it.
The selection in the
example is still manual,
can be automated.
We do it manually because you know,
still some human intervention,
you don't want to apply the
wrong rule to the wrong memo.
Then you get obviously a wrong output.
Then the execution and the monitoring.
It's really going to look like this.
We're trying to bring
together a bank process,
a bank policy, and also
the people in the bank
as like human in the loop layer
and even in the future,
try to bring in the
machine learning model.
That's just the technical
slide that I have to put.
How did we build it?
So I build it leveraging
couple of other technology,
some open source, some of our partners,
everything runs on Cloudera,
Neo4j as a graph database
in order to bring better,
you know, relationship
between various agents.
I did find that it improves
heavily the extraction of agent
to have a graph database on it.
Also use Docling as a document processor
for this particular use case.
There's other technologies
that are possible,
but overall, you know,
we're gonna extract,
find the agent, assess
what are the requirements
and then put it in a graph database.
And when we want to evaluate
the credit proposal,
we retrieve these agents,
assess whether the condition are satisfied
and then get a final memo on it.
This start or do I need to click?
Alright, so this is the
Cloudera AI workbench
where we have deployed an application
that is meant exactly for this.
First step, you know,
is we are going to select a credit policy.
And the credit policy
is one that I made up
based on another bank's policy,
but I can't use exactly
their own policy, obviously.
So it's a fairly standard one
where you have some threshold
that needs to be met
and a lot of rules in it
that's very typical
of what you can find in the bank.
We'll upload it, trigger
the first analysis pipeline,
which is going to
retrieve a set of agents.
The set of agents are
converted into some JSON file,
but first we can obviously select them.
So you will see one example is,
you know the credit report age limit here.
It just states
that the application must
be as recent as 30 days.
Just a very basic rule.
We can also have automated selection.
I implemented it so that I
don't need to bother thinking,
"Oh I need to trigger this
one, this one, this one,
get this agent to run, this agent to run."
And AI will decide which
agents are relevant
for this particular credit application.
Then I upload a mortgage
application in this case
with everything you expect
from a mortgage application,
income and other topics.
The policy was extracted
and some graph, knowledge graph was built.
And this does help a lot in bringing,
let's say relationship
between various rules
so that you can get all the
mortgage rules together.
We also provide observability
through another partner called Galileo.
And in this case, you know,
it does provide insight
on what's going on on the
agent that we are running,
just a basic observability observation.
If we go back to our application.
So it should be finishing, I hope.
Okay, so it does give us an
overall compliance score.
So in this case,
you know the credit report
age limit was selected.
They say it is fine, the credit
report is three days old.
So most likely this particular agent rule
that we define is actually okay.
The bank statement age limit is fine.
Just tell us that the minimum down payment
for first time buyer is actually correct.
I think in this case the
down payment is at 9%
and the credit policy was at 3%.
So it's able to make some computation.
This was not given in
the application memo.
The application memo we stated,
"This is the down payment,
this is the loan amount and
therefore that's how it works."
We used our partner
one more time, Galileo,
in order to assess what's going on
and whether everything run properly.
So we are able to log every single steps
straight from Cloudera AI in order to look
what is the execution.
In this case it's a workflow.
So it goes from left to right
in a fairly smooth manner
and we are able to, you know,
debug if something happened.
Was this the right agent to pick?
Was it executed properly
or does it needs to be
rerun at some point?
That's something quite
useful in order to avoid,
so there's some cost management
in case we are using some
in case we are using some other thing.
That's all for me.
So I think I've been showing,
you know, on Cloudera AI
and leveraging some of
our great partners on AWS,
how we can modernize credit application.
It's not just theoretical on the demo.
I actually implemented this
for one of our customer
in order to double check
what humans were doing.
Let's be realistic.
Agentic AI is still at the infancy
and there's more, like,
there's still a lot
of duplicate checks that needs to be done.
But there's actually a bank
using this in order to,
you know, to check
whether some potential
audit issue are happening
inside the credit risk
origination process.
So I think it's generating great value
and if you want to know more,
please visit us at our booth,
1175 right over there.
We'll be very happy to
discuss more about it.
Thank you very much.